as you mentioned going to some difficult
moments in your life sure
um
what what has been your experience with
uh with depression what has been your
experience getting out of it overcoming
it
yeah I mean the whole thing the whole
journey
um uh with coddling the American mind
began with me
um
in the at the Belmont psychiatric
facility in Philadelphia back in 2007. I
had called 9-1-1 In a Moment of clarity
because I'd gone to the uh the hardware
store to
um
make sure that when I killed myself that
I it stuck I wanted to make sure that I
you know had my head wrapped and
everything so like if all the drugs I
was planning to take didn't work that I
wouldn't be able to claw my way out
it had been a really rough year and I
always had issues with depression
um but they were getting worse and
frankly one of the reasons why this
cancel culture stuff is so um important
to me is that
the thing that I didn't emphasize as
much in coddling the American mind which
by the way that description that I give
of trying to kill myself was the first
time I'd ever written it down nobody in
my family was aware
um of how of it being like that my wife
had never seen it and basically the only
way I was able to write that was by by
doing you know how you can kind of trick
yourself if
um and I was like I'm going to convince
myself that this is just between me and
my computer and nobody will see it it's
probably not the most public thing I've
ever written
um but what I didn't emphasize in that
was how much the culture War played into
how depressed I got because I was
originally legal director of fire then I
became president of fire in 2005 moved
to Philadelphia where I get depressed
um and uh and just I don't have family
there there's something about the town
they don't seem to like me very much
um but the main thing was being in the
culture world all the time
um there was a girl that I was dating
um I remember you know she didn't seem
to really approve of what I did and a
lot of people didn't really seem to and
meanwhile like I was defending people on
the left all the time and they'd be like
oh that's good that you're finding
someone left but they still would never
forgive me for defending someone on the
right and I remember saying at one point
I'm like listen I'm like I'm I'm a True
Believer in this stuff I'm willing to
defend Nazis I'm certainly willing to
defend Republicans
and she actually said I think
Republicans might be worse
um and that didn't that really shouldn't
go very well and then I nearly gotten
fist fights a couple times with with
people on the right um because they
found out I defended people who crack
jokes about 9 11. like this happened
more than once I'm not you know by that
time I'm in my 20s I'm not fist fighting
again
um but yeah it was always like that you
you see how hypocritical people can be
you can see how friends can turn on you
if they don't like your politics so I
got a early preview of this of of of
what the culture we're heading into by
being the president of fire and it was
exhausting
um
and that was one of the main things that
led me to be you know suicidally
depressed uh at the Belmont Center if
you told me that that would be the
beginning of a new and better life for
me I would have laughed if I could have
but I would you know I don't like you
can tell I'm okay if I'm still laughing
and I wasn't laughing
um at that point
so um I got a doctor and I started doing
cognitive behavioral therapy I started
having all these voices in my head that
were catastrophizing and
um you know engaging over over
generalization and
um uh fortune telling you know uh mind
reading all of these things that they
teach you not to do and it and what they
what you do when CBT is essentially you
you have something makes you upset and
then you just write down what the
thought was
um and you know something minor could
happen in your response was you know
like um well the date didn't seem to go
very well and that's because I'm broken
and will die alone and you're like okay
okay what what are what are the
following you know uh that's
catastrophizing that's mind reading
that's a fortune telling that's all the
stuff and you have to do this several
times a day
forever I actually need to brush up on
it at the moment
um and it slowly over time voices in my
head that have been saying horrible you
know horrible internal talk it just
didn't sound as convincing anymore which
was a really kind of like subtle effect
like it was just kind of like oh wait I
don't buy that I'm broken you know like
that doesn't sound true that doesn't
sound like truth from God like like it
used to
and nine months after I was
planning to kill myself I was probably
happier than I'd been in a decade
um
and that was one of the things that you
know that the CBT is what led me to
notice this in my own work that it felt
like administrators were kind of selling
cognitive distortions but students
weren't buying it and then when I
started noticing that they seemed to
come in actually already believing in a
lot of this stuff that would be very
dangerous and that led to cuddling the
American mind and all that stuff
but the thing that was rough about right
enhancing the American mind I'd have
mentioned this already a couple of times
I got really depressed this past year
um because I was studying you know
there's a friend in there that I talk
about who killed himself um after being
canceled I talked to him a week before
he killed himself and I hadn't actually
um
I hadn't actually checked in with him
because he seemed so confident I thought
it would be totally fine because he he
had an insensitive tweet in June of 2020
and uh you know got got forced out in a
way that didn't actually sound as bad as
a lot of the other professors he
actually at least got a severance
package but they knew he'd Sue and win
um because he had before
and so I waited to check in on him
because we were so overwhelmed with the
requester helps and he was saying people
were coming to his house still and then
he shot himself the next week and I I
definitely and because everyone knows
I'm so public about you know my
struggles with this stuff
everybody
um who fights this stuff comes to me
when they're having a hard time and this
is a very hard psychologically taxing
business to be in and even admitting
this right now like
I think about like all the all the
vultures out there if they'll have fun
with it just like the same way when my
friend Mike Adams killed himself there
were people like celebrating on Twitter
um that that a man was dead uh because
they didn't like his tweets and but
somehow that made them compassionate for
some abstract other person so I was
getting a little depressed and anxious
and the thing that really helped me more
than anything else
um was confessing to my staff
that I you know I I books take a lot of
energy so I knew they didn't want to
hear that Not only was this taking a lot
of the boss's time this was making him
depressed and anxious but when I finally
told my the leadership of my staff
um you know people that even though I
try to maintain a lot of distance from I
love very very much
um it made such a difference you know
because I could be open about that and
the other thing was if you're at this
conference dialogue oh yes it's like an
invite-only thing it's Oren Hoffman
um runs it
um it intentionally tries to get people
over the political Spectrum to come
together and have off the record
conversations about big issues
and it was nice to be in a room where
liberal conservative none of the above
were all like oh thank God someone's
taking on Council culture and where it
felt like
it felt like maybe this won't be the the
disaster for me and my family that I was
that I was starting to be afraid of it
would be that taking the stuff on might
actually have a happy ending well one
thing I just stands out from that
is the the pain of cancellation
can be really intense
and that doesn't necessarily mean losing
your job but just even you can call it
bullying you can call whatever name but
just some number of people on the
internet
and that number can be small kind of
saying
bad things to you yeah that can be a
pretty powerful force to the human
psyche which was very surprising and
then the flip side also of that
uh it really makes me sad how cruel
people can be yeah it's such a thinking
that your your cause is social justice
in many cases can lead people to think I
can be as cruel as I want in pursuit of
this when it a lot of times it's you
know just a way to sort of
vent some aggression on on a person that
you think of it only as an abstraction
so I think it's important for people to
realize that they're whatever like
whatever
negative energy whatever negativity you
want to put out there
like there's real people that can get
hurt like you can really get people
um
to one be the worst version of
themselves or two possibly take their
own life and it's not
as real yeah well that's one of the
things that we do in the book
um to really kind of address people who
still try to claim this you know isn't
real is we just quote we quote the pope
we call Obama we put James Carville we
quote Taylor Swift on cancel culture
like
um and Taylor Swift's quote is is
essentially about like how behind all of
this there's when it gets pretty nasty
there's this very clear you know kill
yourself kind of undercurrent to it
um and it's it's cruel and the problem
is that in an environment so wide open
there's always going to be someone who
wants to be so transgressive and say the
most hurtful you know terrible thing but
then you have to remember the
misrepresentation getting back to the
old idioms sticks and stones will break
my bones but names will never never hurt
me
has been
re-imagined in campus debates in the
most asinine way people will literally
say stuff like but now we know words can
hurt and it's like now we know words can
hurt guys you didn't have to come up
with a special little thing that you
teach children to make her words hurt
less if they never hurt in the first
place it wouldn't even make sense the
saying it's a saying that you repeat to
yourself to give yourself strength when
the bullies have noticed you're a little
weird that might be a little personal
um the uh and it helps it really does
help to be like listen Okay are
going to say things
um and I can't let them have that kind
of power over me yeah
yeah it still is a learning experience
because it does it does it does hurt but
for the good people out there who
actually you know just sometimes think
think that they're venting you know they
think about it remember that there are
people on either side of it
yeah for me it hurts my kind of faith in
humanity
um I know it shouldn't but it does
sometimes when I just see people being
cruel to each other it kind of
it's uh it floats
a cloud over my perspective of the world
that don't I wish didn't have to be
there yeah that was always my sort of
flipping but uh answer to that if if
mankind is basically good or basically
evil being like the biggest debate in in
in in in philosophy and being like well
the problem with uh with the first is
there's nothing basic about Humanity
yeah what gives you hope about this
whole thing about about this dark state
that we're in as you describe how can we
get out what gives you hope that we will
get up
I think that people are sick of it
um I think people are sick of
not being able to be authentic and
that's really you know what censorship
is it's basically telling you don't be
yourself don't actually be say what you
think
um don't show your personality don't
dissent don't be weird don't be wrong
um and that's not sustainable I think
that
people have kind of had enough of it uh
but one thing I definitely want to say
to your audience is
it can't just be up to us our viewers to
try to fix this
um we and I think that and this may
sound like it's an unrelated problem I
think if there were
highly respected let's say extremely
difficult ways to prove that you're
extremely smart and hardworking that
cost little or nothing
that actually can give
the harvards and the yales of the world
to run for their money I think that
might be the most positive thing we
could do to to deal with a lot of these
problems and why
I think the fact that we have become a
weird America with a great anti-elitist
tradition has become weirdly elitist in
this in um in the respect that we not
only again are our leadership coming
from these few fancy schools we actually
have like great admiration for them we
kind of look up to them but I think we'd
have a lot healthier of a society If
people could prove you know their
excellence in ways that are coming from
completely different streams and and
that that are highly respected I
sometimes talk about there should be a
test that anyone who passes it gets like
a you know a ba in the humanities that
is like a super ba like some something
like someone not a GED that's not what
I'm talking about I'm talking about
something that like
you know one out of only a couple like a
hundred people can pass some other way
of actually
um uh of not going through these massive
bloated expensive institutions that
people can raise their hands and say I'm
smart and hardworking I think that could
be an incredibly healthy uh way I think
we need additional streams for Creative
people to be solving problems whether
that's on X or someplace else
um I think that there's lots of things
that technology could do to really help
with this I think some of the stuff that
Sal Khan is working on uh at Khan
Academy could really help
um so I think there's a lot of ways but
they exist largely around coming up with
new ways of doing things not just
expecting the old things that have say
40 billion dollars in the bank that
they're going to reform themselves and
and here and here's my you know I've
been picking on Harvard a lot but I'm
going to pick on a little bit more
um the and one and uh I talk a lot about
class again and you know there's a great
book called Poison Ivy um by Evan mandry
which I recommend to everybody it's
outrageous it sounds like me and Iran at
Stanford
um which was uh and I and I think the
stat is you know Elite higher education
has more kids from the top one percent
than they have from the bottom 50 or 60
depending on the school
um and when you look at how much they
actually like replicate class privilege
it's it's really distressing so
everybody should read poison ivy
and above all else
uh if you're weird continue being weird
and you're one of the most interesting
one of the weirdest in the most
beautiful way people have ever met Greg
uh thank you for the really important
work you do this was
this is
I appreciate the class the hilarity that
you brought here today man
um this is an amazing conversation thank
you for the work you do thank you thank
you and for me who deeply cares about
education higher education thank you for
uh holding the mits and the harvards
accountable uh for um doing right by the
people that walk their Halls so thank
you so much for talking today